we don't want to bury any more black
kids we're shedding the streets down
because our nation is has been put on
notice that we're not going away we're
going to continue to keep coming to
Washington DC and to the logs are change
it's not going to stop unless the
government in Washington unless the
president steps in and make something
happen
this one's got the song this should have
been no more dontre Hamilton's this
shouldn't even anymore Trayvon Martin's
there shouldn't have been any more Eric
gardeners there shouldn't be any more
Michael Browns if they do what needs to
be done as we has described today at the
Department of Justice if they implement
these demands we can stop the senseless
killing of our own arm children